[Music]
josh
is with us in indiana hi josh welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi dave thanks for having me i've been
listening to you since my junior year in
high school
so uh glad to be making the call today
mom i'm honored to talk to you how old
are you now
29. wow you've been with us a long time
yep
how can we help that's right so my wife
and i have recently come into a
settlement
where it's 190 000 and we currently have
a 15-year mortgage
that's right now about 207 thousand and
so
what my question is i'm just wondering
would it be the best bet to throw
all of that money onto the house and
just focus on getting that paid
off or since our interest rate is really
low right now
um would it be better to invest that
money
elsewhere or maybe do a combination of
the two i was just wanting to get your
opinion about that
okay well you've been listening to me
since you're a junior in high school so
what am i going to say
pay off the house
[Laughter]
i just wanted to make sure yeah i mean
these rates are just crazy right now
i mean yeah and the question i always
ask people is this see if you've heard
this before
i know you have if your house was paid
for right now
would you go borrow 200 000 on it to
invest
no sir same thing
i like that yeah you've heard you've
heard me say that before haven't you
yep that's right that's right i just
wanted to i'm telling you man i just see
these
low interest rates but i understand i
understand but the point is
when i ask the question in reverse like
that what it causes you to do
is not think only with your mathematical
mind
it causes you to engage your heart as
well your heart is where you measure
risk your mind is where you do math
and so right it kind of there's a little
bit of a
it took your breath away just a little
bit like i'm going to borrow on my paid
for house
just for a little bit and that's that's
not that's the heart doing that that's
not the head
but then the head starts going oh but
these interest rates are really low and
right and they are arguing with the head
but the heart's where you measure risk
and so you get a complete picture when
you do
the measurement both ways and sometimes
a a reverse engineering of that called a
cost analysis
uh doing it the other way like if you
had to paid for house when you borrow on
it
uh will wake you up and help you realize
so yeah you knew that you knew what i
was going to say
and you really knew what you were going
to do you just wanted to hear someone
else say it and that way it didn't feel
as crazy because some of your friends
think you're great i was gonna say
it lowers it lowers the crazy bar when
you have someone else on your team being
like nope
you're good you're good even though it
seems like to defy
everything everyone else is probably
telling you well all the broke people
have an opinion
about money including broke financial
advisor advisors sometimes
yeah you know and they come in you've
got a million dollars they got two
dollars
but they're telling you how to do stuff
you know and so
now it's not a simple it's not
as simple as the mathematical form you
you lose when you don't include risk
is a naive formula because you have to
mathematically plug risk into the